to see the key value pairs that are
stored for a particular site or scheme
host port combination you can open up
the chrome developer tools go to the
resources tab and select local storage
note that there's local storage which
persists across reloads and session
storage which is the same API but it's
isolated by tab and it's clear it at the
end of the session so whenever the page
is closed down the session storage goes
away now remember you can only store
text and local storage so if you wanted
to store an image or some other binary
data type you'd have to first base 64
encoded and of course you only get
typically about five megabytes per
domain so you're not going to be able to
store very much so now it's your turn
use local storage to store the value bar
for the key foo